quoi vous ancien métier tu faisais quoi
bon fifi toi mes anciens métiers
accepter quoi comme petit métier j'ai
mis des prospectus dans les boîtes aux
lettres
aussi je les fais ça c'est vrai ouais
j'ai fait voilà j'étais guichetier à la
banque ah oui au moins un caissier ça
sympa aussi
et toi elodie s'élevant deux serveuses
hôtesses en événementiel vendu des
panneaux solaires
c'est vrai que ça cartonne n'est pas
nouvelle mais savait pas vraiment judas
t'as fait quoi toi moi j'étais animateur
avec les enfants on a lu saint amour
elle c'est plein d'enfants différents et
patient toi ouais on est un amour qui a
fait des métiers un peu insolite autant
vous l'avouer était le plus coté c'est
et ramasseurs de pommes de terre c'est
pas franchement j'ai été très bons en
sac ou en machine et tous les
agriculteurs voulaient me recruter
et après j'ai fait une allergie rue
l'arrivée j'ai fait une allergie aux
pommes de terre et ma carrière avait
fait une allergie romain ça ça me
gagnait les mains et tout ça j'étais
très bon oui oui s'appelle comment
l'énergie aux pommes de terre et je sais
pas bah ouais d'accord vous êtes vicaut
fob frais d'accès droit de la pomme de
terre celui-ci voulait faymann t on le
sait apple
vous avez une fille dans une friperie
oui oui j'adore les fripes web on
s'écrit du script
celle ci s'était bien gentil très beau
nier je vendais des les fringues de deux
vieilles dames et saas et voilà c'est
simple
ah non non non mathieu moi c'est le fait
ici des grands magasins c'est quoi c'est
à dire ou montrer vos fesses
non c'est d'aller dans les allées et je
vais remettre tous les produits qui
étaient datées de la date presque de
péremption de vent pour que les gens les
prêts
oui vous mettez toutes les dates les
plus récentes devant tant que legend est
d'accord avec vous remettez de la
traînée de vapeur le roulement ou
isabelle tailleur de pierre
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
non tu fais côté visa et tant pis si ça
l est plus jeunes toujours me d'âne et
poney c'est vrai wisa même âge en tout
cas parce que la rigolade
non pas quand j'ai mis une dizaine
d'années j'étais promener son chien à
davos mais ça a été une horreur ce qu'à
l'époque je n'avais pas l'histoire des
dominants dominés et donc il se prenait
dans tous les sens et à un voisin il
faut recadrer les chiens jetés
réellement jeté un seau d'eau parce que
je sais pas comment m'en sortir dans
l'échappement certes on est tous
mouillés mais j'ai mis fin à
l'expérience est là aussi j'ai découvert
que des fois par le chaland réformes
peuvent plus se sait pas mais vous avez
dix ans vous donnez va s'arrêter quand
ça les gold façon après il ya eu la
guerre 14 ça s'arrête plus et alors vous
lui faites aux jo oui oui mais contentez
vous de faire si je prenais en mai
bonjour les moules
si je peux vous donner course wiimote et
vous concentrez vous sur les infos
médias n'avaient pas les fans non plus
les gens à l'aise il fait un temps